[Music]  all right let's do this  what's so fun about she-hulk  is that there are a lot of unexpected  [Music]  cameos i will kill for you megan the  stallion oh you are way more fun than my  last lawyer  megan's a really good actor i'm a huge  fan like it was crazy you think of this  huge star but megan was just awesome  i am doing groundbreaking things it's  working in marvel  and i like to think of myself as a  version of thanos  just remember whose show this actually  is  every episode introduces a crazy cast of  people  there's so much more to come in this  wacky world  [Music]  who the hell are you jennifer walters  attorney  [Music]  whether you like it or not trouble's  gonna find you  let's do this  you could be an avenger i'm not a  superhero that is for billionaires and  narcissists  and adult orphans for some reason  she-hulk attorney at law original series  streaming august 18th only on disney  plus  [Music]  you